besserer sex mit sexting musikalische op
und gewaltiger gewichtsverlust in nur
einer sekunde das sind nur drei der fünf
themen heute in den kick zum topf - wer
früher in die schule kommt der leidet
häufiger an adhs dem
aufmerksamkeitsdefizit
hyperaktivitätssyndrom die lmu die
ludwig-maximilians-universität münchen
und das zentralinstitut für
kassenärztliche versorgung zi arbeiteten
gemeinsam an einer studie
darin berichten sie von einer höheren
wahrscheinlichkeit adhs zu bekommen wenn
man sehr jung in die schule kommt aber
spiele schon ein jahr eine große rolle
bei 5,3 prozent der kinder die mit fünf
oder ein kleines bisschen älter ihren
ersten schultag bestimmten konnte adhs
festgestellt werden 43 prozent waren es
bei den gerade mal ein jahr älteren sie
werteten dafür daten aus dem zeitraum
2008 bis 2011 von rund 7 millionen
kindern zwischen vier und 14 jahren aus
doch wie soll man da gegensteuern die
aktuelle stichtage die aktuelle
stichtage müsste man überdenken wer bis
zu dem stichtag so alt wird dass er
eingeschult werden kann wird eingeschult
vor zwölf jahren war das in der ganzen
bundesrepublik der dreißigste juni heute
findet man in berlin den stichtag am 31
dezember
das hat natürlich konsequenzen lernen
schauer am himmel wir berichteten schon
diesen mittwoch auf unserem blog über
die perseiden die perseiden sind kleine
rest teilchen von einem kometenschweif
sobald die teilchen die erdatmosphäre
berühren verbrennen sie das sehen wir
dann von unten aus und es sind die
sogenannten sternschnuppen in der nacht
von mittwoch den 12 nacht auf donnerstag
den 13 achten konnten zahlreiche
sternschnuppen am himmel gesehen werden
im zeitraum zwischen 2 uhr und 4 uhr
nachts an karsten verglühen dieses jahr
konnten wir diesen sternen schaue in
einer seltenen intensität bestaunen die
nachbar sternen klar
und wenn man sich dann noch geschickt
positioniert hatte konnte man die
perseiden in voller pracht genießen
allerdings gab es deutlich weniger
sternschnuppen zu sehen als in den
jahren zuvor statt jede minute gab es
nur alle 5 minuten
eine sternschnuppe zu bestaunen falls
ihr das ganze spektakel nicht beobachten
konnte keine sorge
noch an diesem wochenende sollen
vereinzelt sternschnuppen zu sehen sein
also jetzt am fünfzehnten achten und am
16 08 2015 ein gewichtsverlust von mehr
als 100 kilo pro sekunde zwischen den
formaten showroom auf gerasimenko der
sonne stehen aktuell rund 185 millionen
kilometer lehrer diese strecke ist
unheimlich lang aber dennoch eine der
kürzesten bzw die kürzeste distanz
zwischen juli und der sonne dem dlr dem
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
zufolge heizt sich der komet derzeit auf
80 grad auf dass es ziemlich heiß das
besondere an der aktuellen lage und
dieser temperatur bei theorie ist dass
die forscher hoffen an jetzt mehrere
milliarden jahre altes material zu
kommen
juli schmilzt nämlich derzeit und somit
stößt er immer mehr materie ins all
in einer sekunde können es mehr als 100
kilogramm sein
die raumsonde rosetta konnte eine der
vielen gas fontänen auf zeichnen das
bild zeigt den kometen wie er materie
hier gas ins all befördert wenn die
experten nichts brauchbares finden
können jetzt in dieser phase müssen sie
sechseinhalb jahre warten erst dann wird
der komet wieder in einer derartigen
lage sein wenn ihr von euch an einen
krankenhausaufenthalt denkt kommen auch
bestimmt so gesamten wie schlechtes
essen ungewöhnlicher ja so
antiseptischer geruch etwas unheimliche
op räume und und und und und aber wie
wäre es denn mit etwas positivem einem
op zimmer in dem laut musik gespielt
wird wissenschaftler veröffentlichten im
pharmazie magazin the lancet dazu eine
studie
sie untersuchten 72 schon
veröffentlichte studien um der frage
nach dem einfluss der musik während
einer op auf den grund zu gehen ihre
resultate klingen vielversprechend der
studie zufolge müsse der oder die
anästhesistin weniger zu einer
schmerzlindernden medikation greifen
wenn musik während der op läuft zitat
der musik eine ungefährliche und
günstige therapie ist sollte sie jedem
angeboten werden der operiert wird so
kathrin meets von der brunel university
in ax bridge falls euch mal so eine
musikalische op
angeboten wird dann solltet ihr am
besten auch gleich eure eigene lieblings
playlist abspielen lassen
dies könne den forschern zufolge eine
noch bessere wirkung erzielen besserer
sex mit texting forscher widmeten sich
dem sexting dem erotischen chatten sie
wollten wissen wie sich das schicken von
erotischen bildern oder texten oder
vielleicht auch videos auf das sexleben
aus wenn 870 probanden im alter zwischen
18 und 82 jahren stellten sich den
fragen der forscher die banane zur frage
sollte zunächst am erklären wie viele
von den 870 frauen und männern schon am
sexting betrieben hatten es waren mehr
als 80 prozent sieger man im letzten
jahr nachrichten mit dem entsprechendem
inhalt bekommen oder sogar verschickt zu
haben
in etwa 75 prozent der 870 probanden
waren in der zeit der studie in einer
festen partnerschaft das offener umgang
mit der sexualität in der beziehung mit
sicherheit keinen schaden ist das ist
klar aber wie wirkt sich sexting auf die
beziehung bzw
fairfax leben aus der studie zufolge
bezeichnen
paare die sich gegenseitig nachrichten
mit sexuellen anreizen schicken ihren
geschlechtsverkehr deutlich
befriedigender als ohne
zurück zu offener umgang mit der
sexualität in der beziehung ist mit
sicherheit kein schaden
auch das konnten die wissenschaftler
bestätigen sexting scheint dazu
beizutragen eine glücklichere beziehung
führen zu können warum das fragen sich
die forscher vermutlich auch noch heute
allerdings sollte man beim sexting
beachten was einmal digitalisiert ist
also mit dem telefon fotografiert
aufgenommen gefilmt usw kann auch
schnell in umlauf gebracht werden es ist
ja digital ja und während sich die einen
forscher fragen warum haben die anderen
schon eine menge erkenntnisse gesammelt
musik hilft nicht nur während einer op
sondern ähnelt dem sex mehr dazu erfahrt
ihr im video hier oben zu rap und zum
block kommt er hier unten und lass uns
doch mal wissen woran ihr denkt wenn ihr
an einen krankenhausaufenthalt denkt was
ihr damit verbindet oder erlebt hat und
ob ihr schon mal musik während einer op
gehört habt oder ob ihr das gerne hätte
schreibt es uns in die kommentare und
bis dann bleibt dran